en raison des événements intervenus et
porté à la connaissance de la direction
au cours de l'année 2022 la direction a
décidé de mettre un terme au contrat de
travail de monsieur jean jacques bourdin
est ainsi cessé toute collaboration fin
du communiqué jean-jacques bourdin a
fait l'objet de deux plaintes en début
d'année à l'une pour tentative
d'agression sexuelle en 2013 l'autre
pour agression sexuelle harcèlement et
exhibition sexuelle à la fin des années
80 toutes les deux ont été classées sans
suite car les faits décrits étaient trop
anciens au sein de la rédaction il y a
eu une enquête interne plusieurs médias
rapportent que les conclusions ont mis
en lumière des comportements
inappropriés rien qui ne pourraient
donner lieu en tout cas à des poursuites
pénales mais suffisamment pour justifier
son licenciement
[Rires]
géographie alors je vais prendre d'abord
alors qui dit alors comprenez-vous la
décision de bfmtv de licenciés jean
jacques bourdin je rappelle même la
question comprenez vous la décision de
mes amis du groupe
d'avoir licencié jean luc bronner on va
d'abord prendre pas mal de noms dont
rêvait banon soit pour laval jamais oui
mais là j'ai mis non pas ce que dit la
vérité mais moi je dis oui même si vos
amis je le dis quand même on peut pas
licencier quelqu'un juste parce qu'il ya
une accusation faut laisser faire de
l'enquète deux accusations tu laisses
faire l' enquête s'il enquête à la
beauty et qu'il est accusé la tue le
veer lassé des accusations ou il ya
prescription et même s'il a pas
prescription qu'il est coupable il faut
qu'ils payent et là tu le veer c'est à
dire demain à quelqu'un même pas dans
mon boulot à moi on va m'accuser de
quelque chose et on va me sens sied
mieux
parce que peut-être c'est des médias
donc c'est un truc différent parce que
c'est des médias mais dans la vie de
tous les jours si tu est accusé
d'agression sexuelle n'est pas viré tu
continue quand même à travailler tu
n'auras dirigeants d
après c'est l'éthique question dit il
une enquête interne qu'est-ce que je
recule pas
c'est une très bonne chose c'était une
septième
je vais prendre d'abord des noms après
vous répondrez aux noms guillaume genton
je rappelle que je suis votre producteur
à la radio également c'est la meilleure
décision de 2022
moi cette décision je la trouve injuste
déjà un c'est une très bonne décision de
jean jacques bourdin n'a pas été
condamné par la justice deux le groupe
attise donc a ouvert une enquête en
interne pour vérifier si vraiment il y
avait des comportements problématiques
et selon le monde cette enquête n'aurait
pas fait émerger la nécessité d'engager
des poursuites judiciaires du coup
qu'est ce qui reste comme argument
solide pour s'en séparer dès rumeurs des
messages douteux qui auraient été
envoyés de son compte twitter pour moi
ce n'est pas assez solide en revanche il
aurait un autre argument qui leur aurait
fait comprendre cette décision c'est le
salaire très conséquente en raison d'un
salaire à six chiffres annuels qui
coûtait très cher au groupe donc c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'ils s'en serait
séparé visionneront jean-jacques
voudrait content de cette décision donc
ça arrange les deux parties apparemment
si je rajoute un petit peu vous pouvez
animer la radio ah oui ah oui alors je
passais sais pas combien de temps
ça marcherait qui pensent qu'ils ont
pris à l'audition va voir on va parler
de l'addition de salariés cette décision
elle était inéluctable certes l'enquète
interne n'a pas montré de comportements
pouvant aller en justice mais il ya
quand même des comportements
inappropriés donc au sein de toute la
rédaction plus personne ne voulait
travailler avec jean jacques bourdin il
ya des témoignages qui sont assez forts
et la direction ne pouvait prendre que
cette décision alors le communiqué a été
pesé à la lettre par les avocats des
deux parties et dans le communiqué le
groupe altice et très précautionneux ils
disent en raison des événements portés à
la connaissance de la direction au cours
de l'année 2022 pourquoi parce que
contrairement à tf1 ils ne veulent pas
être accusé tf1 à propos de ppd on leur
avait dit vous saviez là ils ont pesé au
millimètre c'est juste cette année ils
ont été au courant il ne savait pas
avant mais c'était obligatoire ça se
termine comme ça la somme que va toucher
jean jacques bourdin pour partir et très
conséquente quelques heures combien
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
à plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'euros à six chiffres voilà bah oui oui
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
on m'a parlé je vois là on m'a parlé
autour de 500 milles mais ça pourrait
plus ça pourrait être plus son salaire
était très conséquent et lui qu'on sert
à donner des idées avez vous évolué
l'élu il est content parce qu'il s'en
tire bien et va pouvoir craint des
guerriers dont vous avez la réaction de
sa femme qu'est ce qu'elle a dit sa
femme elle a dit la vérité éclatera
sous-entendu ça veut dire que à mon avis
il prépare un livre et que leur vérité
sortira dans un livre dans quelque temps
elle le défend bec et ongles mais elle
savait elle-même qu'il ne pouvait plus
travailler à bfm oui alain b qui dénonce
la triste l'américaine ça devenait
intenable on a vu valérie pécresse quand
elle était venue à une de ces émissions
qui avait fait tout un speech avant même
de commencer l'émission il ya eu
plusieurs témoignages qui sont sortis
depuis encore on en avait parlé ici
témoignage d'une standardiste qui disait
qu'il était caché qui se touchaient en
train enfin bref en la regardant un truc
vraiment atroce alors effectivement les
faits sont prescrits mais c'était assez
grave pour que tous les invités futur
après soit dans la situation de valérie
pécresse à devoir à chaque fois faire un
speech avant même d'être interviewé par
lui et franchement à la télévision c'est
juste pas possible eh oui non peut pas
continuer comme ça on utilise rajoute
qu'il avait bien négocier parce que vous
savez quand on lui avait retiré la
matinale il n'avait gardé que son
interview il avait obtenu gars de garder
le même salaire vous n'avez plus que
quelques minutes à la place de deux
heures trente mais il avait gardé le
même salaire et c'est sur cette base là
qu'il a négocié son départ marque
valais labellisés comme raymond quand il
fait de la radio pas de la radio c'est
le même salaire c'est ça mais moi qui
dois rien mais c'est vrai et si nous
regardons mais sinon blague à part c'est
vrai que on leur aurait reproché ce
qu'on a reproché à tf1 c'est à dire que
si par malheur on venait à avoir
maintenant de nouvelles informations
d'autres cas qui se révèlerait d'autres
d'autres femmes qui on dirait à bfm vous
l'avez repris vous saviez et pourtant
vous l'avez quand même repris ce que ce
qu'on reproche à tf1 avec patrick poivre
d'arvor par ailleurs les faits sont
prescrits son papa fall ils sont voilà
parce qu'ils sont prescrits mais c'est
pas ça veut pas dire qu'il était en sang
a marqué leur problème est éthique aussi
qui se posent à la chaîne 5e pas eu d'
enquête suit ces faits prescrits c'est
ça qui est dingue n'y a même pas eu une
enquête celle enquête interne et qui a
été édifiante évidemment puisqu'on a
même re évoqué l'histoire du carlton et
que dominique strauss kahn et c est ce
que je dois dire ce qui est rentré mon
avis définitivement monsieur bourdin
c'est justement comme tu dit béatrice
son entretien avec valérie pécresse qui
est un 18 janvier là c'était la fin de
sa carrière
que ça parce que carlos dire en début
d'émission voyez je suis venu malgré
ceci malgré cela il est fort le mec